hey what is going on YouTube
now I know the title of this video may
be confusing but there's a purpose
behind it so if you notice the visor
feels a channel has changed a lot I've
added carpool comedy and living out loud
that looks [ __ ] delicious you know in
the past year or so I've made a lot of
poor decisions and financially I'm in a
lot of debt and instead of lying to you
guys this whole time I've decided to
come clean to you and let you guys know
about my severe addiction to prostitutes
and cocaine you Danny the real reason -
why you guys haven't seen so much
content because I've been experimenting
with my channel some things have worked
well some things have failed and some
things I'm still continuing for example
I work on this korean-american Webster
used to say that it did how you say hi
teacher the one this is she buddy and
I've been working on a lot of other
projects such as Gulf War broke apparel
a new movie that I'm working on with my
good friend justin chon and of course
you guys know about mine
two copies sold one for me
I want them your mom but if you're
asking me
white [ __ ] was something that's going so
well for you well to be honest with you
I can't keep doing the same [ __ ] over
and over and be Pappy I have to improve
you know there have been a few concepts
to this channel that have been at the
core of me and one of them is making
people laugh and number two is always
doing it my way
you know and in the process of working
on this channel and trying out new
things I kind of forgot to fill you guys
in and to be honest with you it's not
really responsible of me to just do that
without letting you guys know and I have
to apologize to you guys for that so yes
we're still doing blogs we're still
doing sketches we're still doing new
content but the biggest difference is
now we have a set pp and we have a set
editor so this is what it is guys better
content more consistency new GP new
editor new look welcome to the new
channel